Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is a number you can call anytime
you have anything you want to tell me.
The number is two one nine two.
David P two one nine two.
David P That's two one nine two three two
eight four three seven.
Here's a caller asking why I won't debate
without considering another possibility.
Take a listen.
Speaker 4: Hey, Davey boy Smith me again.
I see you haven't responded to me ever, so
I'm just going to give you this one question.
Speaker 1: OK.
I don't know anything about other voicemails.
This is the only voicemail I'm aware of from
this guy.
Speaker 4: Why don't you ever debate people
who are actually smarter than you like Ben
Shapiro or Candace Owens or Kim Kreuznach?
Hey, I
Speaker 1: don't know who that Kim classic.
I don't know the first to.
I know
Speaker 4: it.
Even Larry Elder Guy, because you know there
why I have a better idea.
Debate Dave Rubin.
Sure.
Or Sean Hannity or the smartest person on
the wall.
Tucker Carlson.
Okay.
Because, you know, just wandering by.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: I am glad to debate any of them.
Have you ever considered?
Maybe they don't have an interest in debating
me either, because they see me as not worth
their time or for whatever reason, don't want
to.
As many of you might remember at the political
media conference politican a couple of years
ago, I was told by organizers You and Kyle
Lynskey will be debating Charlie Kirk and
Candace Owens, and I said, Great, I'll be
there.
We then found out that Candace Owens has not
did not accept that offer.
Later, Candice said, I didn't and wasn't even
presented with that offer.
Now, politican does often do this thing where
they try to play people off of each other
and they go, Hey, we've got Candice and Charlie
to debate you.
You want to do it, and then you go, Yes.
Then they go to Charlie, Charlie, Charlie
and Candace, and they go, Hey, David Pakman
and Coughlin's, you want to debate you?
And they go, now, no, we're not interested.
Sometimes they do lie about who is accepted.
It's unfortunately a common tactic.
Maybe Candace Owens turned it down.
Maybe she didn't.
But the point here is a lot of these folks
have no interest in debating me.
Dave Rubin is welcome on this show.
Any time I tried to get on his show when I
was in L.A. and he didn't want to do it, he
was busy, whatever.
So for a second stop to think that maybe it's
the other people who don't want to debate
me.
All right.
Something to think about.
We have a great bonus for bonus show for you
today.
Today is the launch date for the Truth social
app.
This is Trump's new social media app.
It looks just like Twitter.
I tried to sign up.
Couldn't do it.
We're going to talk about it.
It's a very interesting, interesting project.
The U.S. is now energy independent from the
standpoint of petroleum production and consumption.
Wait, a second, I thought, Trump said.
We're no longer energy independent, but we
were under him.
Well, we've got the facts.
And Joe Biden has canceled four hundred and
fifteen million dollars of student loans,
making him the president who has canceled
the most student loans of any president in
history.
Now we should inflation adjust that, of course.
Very interesting stories, all of which will
be on two days bonus show, which you can sign
up for at join Packman dot com.
Also next Monday, I will be delivering the
state of the show address on Tuesday next
Tuesday.
Joe Biden is delivering the State of the Union
address.
I will be delivering on Monday the state of
the show address, and it is going to be inspirational.
It is going to be thematic in many ways related
to things on the show.
It's going to be very, very good.
I look forward to sharing with you what's
been going on at the David Pakman show.
We will see you tomorrow.
Or if you are a member, join Pacman dot com.
The bonus show starts in mere minutes.